[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's June which marks louder with
Crowder's second annual cultural
appropriation month where each week we
take you to a new and exciting culture
this week we travel to the mysterious
ancient a tasty culture of India
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright you know that sound it's the
sound of the weekend apparently now Oh
glad it with you of course cultural
appropriation month continues to ever
guess that you get a free t-shirt free
t-shirt this we sure is the culture of
India
little known fact about India swear to
you this is true fifty percent of
Indians defecate out in the open that's
true now great country also dhalsim not
a good choice in street don't be fooled
by the stretchiness you think the
stretching us then you realize he is
weak as a yogi from India who doesn't
eat beef producer to mediate video
studio as always is Jared who is not gay
follow him on Twitter and not get Jeremy
Ennis Crowder elevations drawing
conclusions we could mmm
aji Morgan juniors here hey mister
simplified wine calm what's the wine of
the day we have a curry flavored wine
from southern India sounds gay also
contaminated so we have great I think I
ripped a button on this honestly yeah oh
geez these are itchy as hell anymore
she's not gonna be happy Moscow this is
not a good opening we have a Dave Cullen
on the show Dave Rubin it's gonna be a
lot of fun we're just Dave in the hell
out there so Dave Rubin has a gay lover
named de Dave and I'm gonna ditch the
mustache but oh I didn't I didn't see
this you manager 7-eleven well that
makes sense we'll get letters I'm an
owner franchise thank you come again I
took pride in the American Dream I'll
take a penny leave a penny nothing
okay so we'll have them on and of course
we are going to get to this infamous New
York Times piece today that talks about
the the shooting that occurred yesterday
the politicization has already occurred
we talked about this yesterday but it's
occurred it's in the New York Times this
is why they call it fake news we'll get
into all of that and more but right now
let's talk about other news interesting
story na KJ was one who perfect
the legs we go to for you and it's hard
for me to speak so if people listen to
the audio version seeing what it sounds
cuz this glue has glued my face just
like yesterday
Swedish hospitals this is true story
haha our testing defibrillators delivery
via drone nice so dropping the
regulator's by drone flying spider this
is true they say speed kills and they
found that they've been able to deliver
the defibrillators in an average of five
minutes we just die in five minutes 21
seconds that's compared to the 22
minutes on average for the ambulance oh
that's great so that does make a lot of
sense yeah um I commend them for that
for being innovative by the way that the
drones have been doing the Lord's work
in Sweden for a long time now as they've
been using them to airdrop rape whistles
haha save you air traffic control
nightmare okay I'm not trying to get to
that yeah put the hair engulfed and
dropping rate whistles we have a rape
whistle droned we have clearance for
everyone needs clearance I don't know
much of it it by the way little-known
fact it doesn't really work as it turns
out in Sweden this is this is where
cultural is about cultural appropriation
matters because there are cultural
differences here we think of what a rape
whistle is but actually in Sweden it
acts more like a dog whistle rape
whistles actually just serve to attract
more rapists
[Music]
you sound surprised I don't know what
they expect normalize in Sweden with the
rape on a very rocky road for a long
time Nazi than infecting the locals no
Swedish Chef how far you fall and I used
to look up to you
Yoko Ono I just got today Jan I finally
got a credit because she claims she was
a helpful in writing the song imagine so
she officially got a she officially got
a writing credit for the song imagine so
that's why it's suck yeah yeah that's
shed some light on the story whenever I
say that how could you say that it is
such a [ __ ] not only it's just the
melody isn't anything special but it is
a horrible song if you actually listen
to it is changing now apply the word
it's it's a little collectivism and by
the way here to deliver and I used to
get crap but here to deliver a more
accurate version of imagine is our very
own show favourite Owen Benjamin Owen
Thank You Steven I always liked the song
imagine by John Lennon until I really
listened to the lyrics and then I
noticed some stuff so here's my
impression of my reaction to the lyrics
of imagine by John Lennon
[Music]
imagine
possession didn't you write this to the
thirty million dollar apartment it's
easy if you try
I don't have to try John Lennon I'm
actually poor
no he'll be no us so then what's
stopping me from shooting you above us
only sky and where is my Nana
imagine there's no countries damaji moon
- American not Nigeria you limey bastard
you even pay our taxes it isn't hard to
do then get out of America if you don't
believe in countries
it's actually an infuriating song about
communism written by one of the richest
people in America at the time so uh yeah
congratulations Yoko Ono thank you oh
and we appreciate it
cite the original stocks never any good
you go and get yourself a gig sort of
getting assassinated in front of your
boys side penthouse in ruining
everybody's rest of the day thank God my
costume we've tried to have them on the
show yeah I don't think we will ever
feminists all right Albert
Virginia Governor Terry McAuliffe I got
to make sure I got his name right he
claimed a press conference that gun
violence kills 93 million Americans per
day yes really
I have long advocated this is not what
today is about but there are too many
guns on the street we lose 93 million
Americans a day to gun violence I mean
I've long talked about this I don't know
what you're thinking
that sounds bad on its surface but
surely that was just a one-time gap but
this obviously would 93 million people
day it's just something like yeah yes
that's right of course what questions on
is blatantly fallacious numbers the
governor claimed was dyslexic and when
they inform him that dyslexia only
affects letters not numbers he drank a
bucket of salt water craft himself and
went unconscious so don't expect a ton
of reasons but 93 million Americans one
of the things you country think it seems
so high that you're like maybe there's
something that I'm missing so here to
make sure we get this right is our on
the field
corner yes or on the field
Patrick reporter because you couldn't do
this from home so a lot of clutter on
the field fact-check reporter I think
you're there can you answer me is his
claim that ninety-three million
Americans lose their lives a gun every
day is that is that true what I believe
we've cleared that up thank you very
much mister fat check reporter on the
field
[Music]
it's always useful yeah television has
people out in the field yeah I think
we'll make good use of him busy street
to her he just goes in the field and
uses his iPad really just the travel
expense but clever why good gig if you
can get lover alright so this is before
we have to get to our guest soon but
this was a New York Times Peter saw why
people use the term fake news this was
in the New York Times we read it this
morning we knew right away we wrote
about a lot of credit come all that the
politicization in the wrong way about
this tragedy not the politicization in
in the way that the guy was a radical
leftist Bernie supporter who wanted to
kill people because of their political
beliefs politicization gun control so
there was a piece called rhetoric and
bullets written by Charles M blow in the
New York Times and it's so riddled with
bulk rap gentlemen I think I think this
requires a conference call have you been
reading this this article here in The
New York Times have you seen that today
yet yes no the very first paragraph
reads in 2000 was gravely injured and
six others were killed by shooter in
Tucson they opened the column by
referencing a shooting that occurred
years ago yeah but what what else does
it go on to say yes Republican
personalities and officials in the wake
of Barack Obama's election had spoken
openly about the Second Amendment
remedies and being armed and dangerous
and revolution but it was not possible
to connect the dots between that
irresponsible talk and Tucson shooter
say he says connect the dots Regina or
something the quotes no references are
completely unsubstantiated
yeah well it def
really does seem as though as though
it's pretty clear I'd agree I know you
clearly knows the motive what let me
just get down okay then he writes as
Kathy Waldman wrote for slate last June
this is the New York Times and one of
the first source links in the piece is
slate that's its first reference better
but given it's a phone really slate
that's a first one that's not surprising
though is it give me worse oh okay
couple paragraphs down he writes the
shooter identified as James T Hodgkinson
appears to have had strong liberal ng
Trump ng Republican views sounds like
we're going in the right direction
then they said some other thing she was
a volunteer for the Bernie Sanders
campaign I like this is going but at the
time of this writing authorities had not
announced a motive for the shooting not
announced a motive after the tamerica
that's what we call self explanatory
like a pretty obvious pivot if if a
stretch of a point I know okay there's
some real books he writes on a hint of
irony in this paragraph and I quote what
I bore is ideological exploitation that
reduces these acts to a political sport
and uses them as weapons to silence
political opponents and their rhetoric
Oh
quick take you to wait would your body
buddy take one do you check - okay as
the Washington Post reported for
Wednesday's shooting was the 154th
shooting so far this year in America
that's 154 mass shootings it is 165 days
violence particularly gun fires is the
Americans fact the American shame okay
this country has a
and culture yes that's true we drove a
violent culture in one place this issue
by denying the fact that the shooter was
a Bernie Sanders supporter instead
pivoting to come control to politicize
okay you sound like you're getting a
little you selling you're getting a
little worked up I can't hear you uh I
can't hear you that well what's going on
there so here I must take a stand in
defense of rhetoric while rhetoric
should never promote violence it needn't
be timid didn't be timid
do you mean like you kind of read it
it's Tim Kaine calling for fighting in
the streets or or timid like Kathy
Griffin holding up as never had a fresh
and Donald Trump in emulation Oh Isis or
timid like assassinating President
Donald Trump or Shakespeare in the Park
with Fareed Zakaria butchered CNN
claimed was a masterpiece or dearly
timid like when Huffington Post claimed
that in the wake of Trump era violence
is a totally reasonable answer that
Cargill
yeah I hear you both the minute it
definitely does seem as though uh
there's been a culture of violence it
does seem like there's been a shift in
tone i but you know you do have to
wonder how much of it for which the left
is culpable if at all
well that's very astute because the edge
of that violence might be right here he
concludes the article by writing in some
rhetoric is necessary unreal I believe
Donald Trump and republican-led Congress
are jumping into very serious harm to
the country and its most vulnerable
citizens and I will never stop saying so
in the strongest terms I could summit
for many people this isn't an abstract
policy debate between partisans for them
these debates like about repealing the
Affordable Care Act for example there's
about life and death but that has
nothing to do with the motion of
physical violence it has everything to
do with protecting the country from
administrative and lad
okay thank you both man thank you
no yeah right well that's I think I
think he's done he is very helpful but
you know what the man is very passionate
and sometimes that's just part of the
struggle we have did Cullen coming up
next and then Dave Rubin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we had the head dude you got a pirate
game I think oh what a cut the head but
see who they could tie dumb Motorhead
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
don't
[Music]
but it he had a key but the didn't he
[Music]
[Music]
but I took it I did yeah go ahead
Hey
[Music]
[Music]
all right glad to have our next guest on
the program we missed him we were in
Ireland and we were going back and forth
on on Twitter direct message his YouTube
channel I hope I get this I'm gonna get
the number wrong as youtube.com slash L
ACK 78 78 Dave Cullen on on the Twitter
what it did Colin f SC f c/f Dave at did
: C F at Dave Colin C F at Dave con CF
because now three times will make up for
it Dave call it thank you for being on
the show sir thank you for having me
Stephen what what happened why did you
just put on that creepy voice I have no
idea my profession this behavior I need
to appropriate Englishness or something
this is cultural appropriation night
again is it not this is yes
India today we it's because to
appropriate is to appreciate one's
culture right so Fanta yeah we we go all
out this is not get your justice is up
on the street this is Texas week mm-hmm
yeah Texas lot of Indians have relatives
who live there a lot of Indians in those
neighborhoods because of the tech jobs
so to a certain point was just like
their neighborhoods that are entirely
Indian yeah the only markets are Indian
markets which I mean it's good you know
what behind it delicious stuff
everywhere mr. Cullen first off why why
did you not come out and see us in
Ireland what well firstly I only find
out that you're you're in Ireland when
you you message me in DM said hey come
on out to the show we're starting in an
hour and a half thousand three I'm three
hours it's it's not a big country from
three hours away I know what happened
they're gonna ask you you went to Ennis
yeah why why they're straight to the
Cliffs of Moher and then you went to
Ennis
yes okay so uh senator Rick Santorum's
daughter was getting married and so
there was a big wedding there at the the
Drummond Dromoland castle yeah well so
yeah we were there and so that kind of
dictated where we had to be and then
this one bar pub was Lucas bar hookah
spa and anis said sure we'll host you
and the guy was really nice for someone
he was personally left but was really
respectful and in lettuce broadcast from
there so it was kind of determined by
who would have us but yeah I just would
have loved if you'd gone to Moneygall
you know you know if Moneygall I don't
you don't Oh
I can't believe you don't sow Moneygall
is this very small rinky-dink rural town
in the middle of nowhere between on the
border of awfully and temporary and it's
basically the entire town has become a
shrine to Barack Obama oh how could I
know you should write travel commercials
yes yes can't wait I have to go and see
this because he visited there that was
his an ancestral home and he they have
American flags on other side of the
street and every store the hardware
store the pub the restaurants everything
is something Obama you know named now
and it was hilarious when he was here
because he went to Moneygall and he went
to see the ancestral house so he goes in
and the thing is they're like this is
must be very moving for President Obama
to finally see the ancestral home of his
relative who okay very tenuous
connection to his relative this was not
the original home okay this this
building had been demolished 150 years
really so he was just walking into
someone random person's house you know
this must have been the original Wi-Fi
connection that they had thank you as
you can see that's the Xbox 360
controller back then they didn't even
have one it was still 60 sorry I know
Irish people will get mad if we even do
the accent but any time I talk about
someone I do impressions of what they
sounded like people selling stones The
Cliffs of Moher is just by the way
really boring stones faces we sell
stones like lime stones igneous
sedimentary ever seen it I've never been
to the Cliffs of Moher I've done very
little tourism in my own country
do you suffer no no no Sapphire just
your basic just your your granite you
have grind up stones it's like why are
you selling these why are you here
because I got to show off at 10:30 to
work it was at nothing was open I'll say
this about Ireland nothing was open it
went in multiple towns until 9:30 they
laughed at us when we said we wanted to
get coffee at 8:00 I'm sure that's
probably probably different in downtown
Dublin but it seems like that was pretty
normal across the rest of Ireland yeah
Dublin is this cosmopolitan as as any
where I often joke now that there's
there's a large Irish community in
Dublin actually it's that there is it
everything is open relatively early so
it's
yeah I mean it's it's like a mini London
in that sense but when you're out west
particularly it's as rural as it gets so
it's a very very much slower pace of
life which I I'm quite fond of when I
when I do some traveling around the
country listen I get that I will tell
you this I don't never want to insult a
country land but because so many people
are saying it is life changing and a lot
of these people at the wedding they
would go back every year like I'm good
Ireland was good but you know it could
just because rain went The Cliffs of
Moher it's raining I mean it's nice but
I don't need to come back again namely
just because it just we have all of that
in the States like I thought the country
if you actually see like New England in
the fall or even like Northern Michigan
the dunes and the cliffs that we have we
have a lot of that topography so I was
expecting something I guess I guess
everything we're like pylons which of
course you know that's that's Scottish
so but a beautiful country people were
very very nice one thing we talked about
and you could probably you'd probably
know about this better than I would when
asked individually you know if people
watch our live broadcast from the pub
people were much more right-leaning than
they thought but then they would say you
know you screwed up boat hitter I
couldn't next time and it was like wait
a second you just said we need to do
something about Islamic terrorism and
radicalization in Ireland why why is
that disconnect there there's always a
kind of ahead you gonna find that but
you got to remember political
correctness that that little worm that
gets in your head like it's just it's a
virus it still operates in people's
minds I think so they they'll say things
to you and be quite honest and they say
you know oh you know this isn't whatever
but then they'll always hedge they'll
pull back just a little bit on Obama I'm
all for you I'm not racist but my
country is changing before my very eyes
they always pull back just a little bit
right so it's it's in it with the with
the media here and and what's happened
in college campuses as well we have much
of the same stuff that's a little bit on
a lower boil and what you have in Canada
United States but it's it's very left
you know in there's nothing positive
that will ever be said by orti news or
TV 3 or any of the other mainstream
publications here or any of the Irish
Times or the independent about Donald
Trump it will always be something
negative and I think it does have an
effect on people well you just said less
so maybe than the United States and
Canada what you would think your your
media is less left-leaning no I mean I
mean the colleges probably aren't
okay yeah they don't quite have the
weaponized leftist autism there yeah
yeah it's it's the left by default
position not necessarily though we're
gonna try and stab a policeman with a
flagpole and a silver nail because we're
an toughie type people sometimes yeah
yeah we we have some anti feh guys and
I've had I actually had my first threat
from anti felony a few few weeks ago so
you know I'll see I'm doing something
right is that what I have the beard is
it like padding or would act like grip
tape and absorb make the shock absorbed
erect ly to create bluntness yes loses
his fist in my face yeah so okay so what
do you where do you think this goes in
with Ireland because you think it's not
as bad in the in the colleges and I did
find I will say funny enough the one guy
who was an absolute dick remember who
said I didn't want to talk to me he
would only talk to my wife even though
she's far more to the right than I am
but she's hot it was he was from London
remember his from London and he hated
Donald Trump and said he wanted to see
him die and I said only but all the
Irish people who disagreed were still
pretty respectful which surprised me
considering how default left they were
not aggressively left would you say
that's that's more common there or or is
that transitioning now where they're
becoming like American social just maybe
there's drunk maybe they were drunk
there is but I think it's it's strange I
mean maybe it's just he's coming from
the UK and they've had political
correctness a hell of a lot longer than
we have but I I think in general there
has been a breakdown and this is
something that you know you've spoken to
stefan molyneux about as well
Ireland used to have have this presence
of being quite monolithic with respect
to the judeo-christian values and
Catholicism almost obviously to an
extreme and the Catholic Church had a
very cast iron grip on pretty much
everything yeah but I think that we've
we surrender that by degrees gradually
and there are some people in a way I
think I think I think of Ireland less
like a future Sweden which it may very
well be yeah but more like the way I
keep hearing people saying Texas Texas
becoming more liberal because a hell of
a lot of people from California moved to
Texas and they're going to bring the
right
so I heard timer this morning was from I
think you probably heard that on this
show yes yes we talked about it a lot
all right continue yeah no I think it is
and so it's just I think it's just a
matter of time before you're gonna see
that critical mass but look I mean I I
try and avoid talking politics in in the
pub when I do it's very it's always kind
of very hushed whispers by me to
like-minded soul you know yeah it's like
yeah you know if I'm in feminism or
social justice or Trump or whatever you
can't say anything can't say that we're
and so it's tough and most everybody has
bought into the political correct lies
so The Scotsman didn't care at the pub
Murray was the one guy you know so what
do you think he said he was the drunken
Scotsman came in he was like I don't
know if that's just part of their
culture he just couldn't care less if
the people in the bar wanted to kick his
ass
we had hustle him off so you know it's a
dream that you talk about that and then
I want to get to the YouTube front but
you mentioned sort of Catholicism having
an iron fist in in in Ireland you know
in Quebec that was the case I was raised
in in Catholic public schools and
obviously if you look at people who
identify more as people who believe in
God or are Christians far far lower all
across Europe than in the United States
where we had no state and forced
religion or denomination and so often
people think we're going to actually
have a Catholic apologist come on and
talk to me about this
they confuse this as anti-catholicism
more than I say actually no I just need
you to understand it's anywhere the
Catholic Church has ruled politically
it's lent itself to corruption and then
people reject faith you see beautiful
cathedrals in Ireland completely no one
intends them yeah yeah nobody is a
classic example of that might have been
this is perhaps one of the more
controversial videos that I that I
uploaded but it was with respect to the
2015 it was it was the gay marriage
referendum that we had here the marriage
equality referent and I think a lot the
only real somewhat credible no know side
campaign was was the Catholic Church and
I think a lot of Irish people felt this
has always been my theory as to why
Ireland has become as liberal as it is
it was a pendulum swing against the
Catholic Church they thought it's a
zero-sum game in order
for the Catholic Church to lose and they
must lose we must vote yes because there
no and that's that was just simply that
and so I I think it's very similar to
what you're describing it's a case of
look you lose the bet look I'm an
atheist myself but I've passed the angry
atheist phase I think a little bit like
Stefan because I know you guys spoke
about this recently on the show and it's
it's a little bit a case of look the
values were useful for with respect to
family and and and building a
civilization as a key pillar of your
nation and we've surrendered that so I
think what you what you end up having is
this values vacuum and it's gonna be
filled by relativism and relativism is
just simply going to say well if all
cultures are basically created equally
then we have to accept the culture that
is intolerant of every other culture
yeah so if you tolerate that what do you
think is gonna happen that one is going
to be the dominant one so that's
ultimately the fear is that in a sense
that there's moral relativism that we
have now from the left is a transport
vehicle a Trojan horse that will that
will enable the Sharia is Asian every
country what kind of secularization
we've talked about creates a vacuum and
off in Islam if you look at their
political prescription they talk about
filling those vacuum and it's and how to
do so it's penetrated even the Christian
communities where you see people taking
verses saying the idea that all humans
are created equal sure under God but and
then like they said therefore cultures
must be all I see is must be created
equal and they're not final point cuz we
actually wouldn't a I'm surprised how
quickly this feels like it's going along
we have to bring you back and next time
we're in Ireland if it happens or if
you're stateside let me ask you this do
you think because you've seen this
happen in Europe because I've noticed
this a lot of sort of classical liberal
atheists in Europe are those who fight
the most for freedom of speech and
against political correctness
particularly on YouTube you've covered
this really well in a very fair approach
to what YouTube is doing and how they're
de monetizing videos in the self
censorship do you think you have maybe
an extra sensitivity because you've seen
it happen culturally kind of where you
live and now you're seeing it happen
online digitally youyou mean that we
kind of feel like hey they're just
coming after all specifically yeah well
you said all cultures and ideas are
created equal right this is the idea
kind of
Europe therefore that means you can't
offend any of these cultures or ideas
and that's the stance YouTube's taken
and obviously Facebook and you've talked
about that well yeah no absolutely as
I've said before the Community
Guidelines of these social networks are
it's easy for a government simply place
pressure on a corporation and say change
your Community Guidelines because
ultimately we look at them they are the
future laws set in stone it's harder and
it takes a little bit longer with it
with you know a political bureaucracy to
get laws passed but you know you look at
what's there with respect to hate speech
on Twitter or Facebook or YouTube and
you are you are reading the future
legislation of your countries which is
what you're seeing in the likes of
Canada with bill C 16 or 80 bill 89 or
or m103 or whatever it might be or the
hate speech laws that be brought into
the UK you're reading what will few what
will rule you in the future I think yeah
and do you think that that'll be
self-correcting because of the market on
you - I mean conservatives people like
you and even myself they dominate the
YouTube political sphere right now it's
not even close because there's been such
a pendulum swing back do you think
YouTube will have to respond to market
forces or do you think they'll just
they'll commit digital suicide I I think
they will commit digital suicide I'll
tell you why I wouldn't have thought
that if they weren't focused on
developing YouTube TV and I still think
that YouTube TV will create a two-tier
YouTube so you're gonna have this new
on-demand streaming service that they're
developing for ridiculous $35 a month
and they're placing I think more of
their eggs in that basket or got to
remember that YouTube is not profitable
for Google right so I think what you're
gonna also on YouTube TV the only
YouTube aspects of it are the heavily
curated can't the trending feed right so
even I don't rank there and also YouTube
bread yeah so I'm not really seeing this
love for the grassroots content creators
that built the platform and made it what
it is right now so I'm not convinced
that we're gonna have a long term future
on this platform but thankfully there
are others emerging well that's why we
created a mug club and stefan molyneux
is a member and will see our TV because
we still think it's very important to be
on YouTube since they hate us since it
is so left ironically having people
support us off-site yeah pay for premium
content is what allows us to create more
free content what now where can people
support you on patreon for now I guess
which is one system and you know if you
want to throw me a dollar over on vid me
which is also has a kind of similar
system for premium subscriptions yeah I
maybe we can talk about our fare because
we're going to obviously we have
everything at at CR tv.com and lauder
with credit comm but we'll want to get
it on another video platform because
right now it's YouTube and Facebook and
it's so awful it's awful Dave Cullen
thank you so much sir we'll have to have
you back soon
next time we're in the same country it
could be never yeah
many of you are still unaware of the
items available at louder with Crowder
shop calm not only do they make you look
and feel better but they serve a
multitude of purposes like our socialism
is for five shirts assisting in
identifying potential allies I think
it's pretty funny or our bad hombres
firearm t-shirt helping you know who to
avoid I might have take that shirt to
mean you support some kind of firearm
registry or this one hey look it's my
face I hate it though louder with
Crowder shop calm isn't for everyone but
can I buy them up from the shop without
joining the Month Club no the rest of
you check out the merchandise at ladder
with Crider shop comm today
[Music]
all right glad to have our next guest on
the program unfortunately we're going
today from Pittsburgh but we can't tell
because it's got the lieutenant cab
ready glasses you know I'm for the
wonderful show Ruben reports we've loved
watching mr. Ruben come along the trail
here what are you doing in Pittsburgh's
oh well Crowder I don't like to brag but
I am in Pittsburgh right now you know
some people vacation on Islands people
go to Hawaii or your Cabo your your
Cancun that sort of thing I go to
Pittsburgh I'm actually here I'm with AR
iodine Rand Institute and I did a live
Reuben report last night for about 500
people all talking about free speech
although if you judge by the YouTube
comments it just means that I'm now I've
even further dissented in too far right
all right white supremacists you know
your your kind of stuff crowded yes
again because I've hang it because I'm
hanging out with these people even
though I'm meeting just great lovely
young college kids who all want to fight
for for free speech and your ability to
think on your own which apparently is a
far-right rallying cry these days well I
will say this though I mean you really
you were kind of you said you're a
centrist kind of more sent center-left
still you think the Liberal Democratic
Party has left you but I mean you do
have to admit a and Rand conference
you're kind of going the other direction
on that one that's a curveball even fee
for your well no you know it's funny
these guys they approached me I had had
your own Brook who who you should
definitely have on your show sometime
he's the president of the organization I
had had him on my show and just had a
chat like I would with anyone else with
you or anybody and and they approached
me and just to say you know do you want
to do some stuff on colleges about free
speech and I said look if we don't have
to agree on all the economic stuff if I
don't have to be an Objectivist myself
if we can just do free speech and if we
agree on that then that to me supersedes
everything else so yeah I'm getting some
flak for hanging out with them but I
don't regret it and you know you know
what it's like yeah you do anything if
you do anything with associate with
anyone that you're your intellectual
opponents don't want you to you're gonna
get hate so I leave my judgment up to
myself which I'm probably harsher than
these morons anyway well yeah well you
know I've actually gotten that recently
from believe it or not we talked about
as Catholics just because I've talked
about
I'm not a Catholic and I was recently at
the Catholic wedding it was beautiful it
was in Latin but I still don't agree
with some of the theology and I said you
know if someone can come on in convert
crowder we can make a thing of it in
people why is your anti-catholic been
showing me hold on hold on I was at a
Catholic wedding like a table number two
in Ireland where they gave out rosaries
I'm not anti-catholic I just don't agree
with all of it so everyone's got their
own thing it seems like everyone's free
speech until it's their thing I wonder
if that still applies to some of these
college students yeah well of course it
does look we all have ideological
consistencies there I say crowder even
you and I saw strips if somebody was to
delve deep enough into the to the minds
of the two of us they might find
something intellectually inconsistent I
don't know I never taught my hem top my
head but yeah I mean look you know it's
funny you say that about Catholics
because I lately I'm getting a ton of
email from Catholics and Christians in
the middle of the country saying wow
it's just refreshing to hear of a
liberal that isn't just condemning us to
hell so it is sure that's and that's
actually listening to us and you know
that's why I've had Bishop Baron from
the Archdiocese of LA on my show and
just today we posted an interview with
Rabbi David Wolpe from from Sinai Temple
in Los Angeles and I'd be happy to talk
to any mom or whoever or an atheist or
whatever when we vet Imams shout around
the show wanted me to die so that kind
of wonder we had to create an entirely
new account just to call and I'm really
putting those like bitcoins to my credit
use my account and the first thing you
guys were calling so what are you
calling from we're like oh you know West
wait a minute so you were basically
funding terror hey no no no no we didn't
fund Hannah Coyne it was for us to be
able to purchase Skype credits to call
him oh yeah yeah no I wouldn't I
wouldn't give him any I wouldn't give
him any money the man the man hasn't
earned it um well you know depending who
you ask I guess a different structure
different folks let me ask you out this
today or today now we know what happened
yesterday we know what happened with it
with the shooting them we're talking
with the first one thank God no one no
one was killed except for the scumbag
who brought the rifle give'em baseball
game we kind of knew right on the outset
there are enough reports I kind of
thought it was suspect when he shot at
the Republican dugout I thought that was
a giveaway he wasn't the general
spray-and-pray
these Republicans are Democrats I'm
gonna shoot at that dugout and well we
both we we may never know this young
man's motives
this comes in the wake of an tyfa this
comes in the wake of the Kathy Griffin
who has every right to do what she did
this comes in the wake of assassination
of Trump but Shakespeare in the park and
CNN's Fareed Zakaria says it says it's a
masterpiece
I remember when they tried to blame
gabrielle Giffords on Sarah Palin
because she had a congressional map with
targets of seats that were up for grabs
do you think as someone who's more of a
centrist I truly believe that there is a
tone shift and there's a culture of
violence that is okayed by the left
today which concerns me yeah I mean look
this is basically what I've been talking
about for the last three years now that
that the Liberals are abandoning
liberalism which is based in logic and
reason and live-and-let-live they're
abandoning it for progressivism which of
course as you know is this collectivist
ideology and that way anyone that turns
against it has to be purged out so the
language because they use these words of
racist and bigoted and homophobe and all
this stuff because they label everyone
that they disagree with not not just
some of us but everyone that steps off
the range gets labeled with this stuff
well if you label everybody that's your
intellectual opponent has a Nazi well
then obviously you've now painted
yourself into a corner where the only
logical step now is violence so there
I've been pushing themselves into this
corner I I did a video at the beginning
of the year I think it was my first
video of the year where I said that that
2017 is going to be the year of
misdirected anger and I think that's
very obviously what's happening that
these guys have now they've tacitly
endorsed it the language the look I
defended Kathy Griffin's statements I
destroyed Bill Maher's statements which
is a whole other thing you know what he
got in trouble for a couple weeks ago
yeah the play is it's all kind of gross
the play is kind of gross that cat what
Kathy did kind of gross but I am a free
speech absolutist you have to take that
in the short text of art but but to your
bigger point to your bigger point yeah
they have been slowly going in this
direction where if you keep saying Trump
is Hitler all of these people are Nazis
the GOP is all fully evil people and the
Conservatives are
all trying to kill kill everybody and
and hate minorities well then of course
you're gonna get people doing this
that's just point blank let's say you
believed right now okay let's say you
actually believed that Trump was a Nazi
meaning you actually believed trumpets
have their meaning he was killing
innocent people who or or political
dissidents and you believe he was doing
it in massive numbers wouldn't violent
steps be appropriate if that were the
case well there's an interesting
philosophical discussion to be had on
that that you know if if Hitler if you
knew years before what Hitler was gonna
do would it be ethically or morally
applies here because I'm saying if you
already knew that he was doing it now
which is basically what the left is
saying my point is of course you can
excuse reacting violently if you think
Trump is killing Jews or blacks or
liberals or whatever if you think that
if you genuinely think that yeah you're
gonna act out violently I know that if I
believed Barack Obama was what was
gassing Christians because he was a
secret Muslim born in Kenya if I
actually believed that I'd be like okay
there needs to be more than a harsh
letter and you know III do wonder how
much of it is them just wanting an
excuse to act out versus people who've
actually bought into the rhetoric and
believe it like this shooter it's hard
to delineate now well let's be clear
about this first off is it true I don't
want to spread a rumor but I heard that
this guy might have volunteered for the
Sanders campaign it's true
yes okay okay so already Sanders
acknowledged it of course okay so I've
been running around over here so I'm a
little a little behind so okay so if
that's true and then I saw all his
facebook posts and all that stuff yeah
well imagine if it was reversed and this
was a guy who volunteered for Trump and
had all you know info wars and crowder
and all this stuff see what I did there
I see Megan I could appreciate the Jim
wait by the way can we pause for a
second because you are seriously
culturally appropriate in something with
that presence its cultural appropriate
its cultural appropriation month because
to appropriate is to appreciate cultures
and this week is India again I'm a
little behind on things so look if it is
in the reverse and it was a guy that
volunteered for Trump and and and all
that and and we saw the sights he was on
everybody we know what the narrative
would be everybody would
going bananas everybody would be
demanding Trump apologize and all that
sure and it's like look this is what the
left has been cultivating I don't blame
Bernie for this
I don't blame Bernie I only blame the
person who did it and the ideology where
it came from this is why I've been
spending so much time on the left and I
think I'm saving some of the refugees of
the left the the people that don't want
to be zombified right but there's a huge
there's a huge battle here well I think
that I think it is something that and I
reasons the reason I think that now
you're at the same ran somebody if
people say that's extreme I don't think
it is but I think the reason that
there's kind of this natural trajectory
for everyone who is no longer a hardcore
leftist I will say this you could walk
right in there right now you could walk
into college Republicans and just yell
out I'm gay and I like gay marriage and
you would never fear violence we had to
fear being Pro right-to-work states if
we went to Union rallies we had to fear
going to you know the Occupy Wall Street
if we said that we don't believe in the
policies of Barack Obama conservatives
have always had to fear violence if they
go into leftist territory
whereas it does happen but it's not the
rule and every person who was a former
liberal who we've had in the show I've
talked with personally has said there is
a different tone where now that I'm on
the right or even Center I fear I have
to keep my head in a swirl when I go to
the leftist stuff if I disagree we
talked about yesterday we talked about
how even the people that are labeled
far-right extremists like the Portland
stabber like the Dilla roof's registered
Democrats Bernie supporters themselves
yeah yeah and look look we're not
private investigators so you don't want
to go garner and glean too much
information from what the guy had on
Facebook or any of that stuff you have
to wait and see see but you can take
some taste from that but but your point
is totally right look I did a thing as I
said 500 people there last night I got a
standing ovation I was making jokes
about being gay married now the the
point though that you're getting to is
because these ideologies whether whether
you fully buy objectivism or not is
irrelevant but any ideology that's more
based in the individual and in liberty
you're going to be more tolerant of
other people so for for me I only get
invited to colleges from the
Republicans conservatives of tomorrow
the students for liberty blah blah blah
I never I mean I kid you not
zero Crowder zero invites from Democrat
this progressive that anything he
married pro-choice proleague ization of
marijuana against nation-building I'm
against the death penalty
so who's the tolerant side you know yeah
I know and I you know and I here's one
thing I do appreciate about you
you know we had mark Duplass on a second
time we had him on then and then I know
he's sort of making the rounds which
were really happy to see him do but I
know the second time we had him on he
just he said some things I disagreed
with I said well you know what mark I
appreciate come on the show but I have
to correct that because that is
factually inaccurate and he was a little
taken aback he felt well I don't want to
be combative I just want to listen and I
appreciate that
but I do think listening is only
valuable if it is in search of truth and
I do appreciate that even if you have
people on your show you're civil but
you're one of the few people who is
civil and will still challenge guests
and still ask questions and take an
opposing viewpoint without being like
you're a dick so I do appreciate a mad
about about you final that's that's why
I just real quick I mean that's why I
will always consider you more of an ally
than people that supposedly are on my
team that don't share that sentiment
about what conversation is all about you
know we we don't have to agree on
everything at all the fact that we could
do this and I know you're a decent guy
and guess what we live in a frickin
pluralistic society of 300 million
people get what you got to learn to
tolerate other opinions unless you want
to live in North Korea or in Germany
1942 yeah or or North Korea I think any
42 just take it take any to be here
ending our study with to any time on the
clock with the two anat okay
we wouldn't 2017 you know god yeah I
know and this is Bernie thinks this is
fresh he thinks European socialism is
fresh and new it that's another topic we
discussed this week we'll get back into
a Rubin report on you to reveal can find
you final question I don't even said you
joke about being gay married when you
get gay married do you exchange
mirror-polished glasses is that
I know it's really it's so sad here
because I like outside of whatever the
hell this is that I do is so boring and
regular and we eat dinner and we watch
Seinfeld and we go to sleep and then we
walked it you know we wake up and walk
the dog like really I will forever
picture you doing those things with
these Cobra glasses that they are just
absolutely hypnotizing they're very nice
I just know you're so you are so
generally kind of reserved The Bling is
a little unexpected but you know it
works it works the Las Vegas I'm trying
to be intimidating here on the mean
streets of Pittsburgh you know yeah
today with your glasses in your white
iPhone all right that is youtube.com
slash Ruben report thank you for taking
the time sir and stay safe because I
hear they're aggressive we're in fact
that home body friends with Stephen
Prouty
and not gay Jerry someone's a great time
to be active and enjoy some of your
favorite activities outside like riding
a bicycle even better it's a great time
to keep a new friend but most important
safety first ensuring that people are
wearing the right gear to ensure a
pleasurable and injury-free experience
it's also paramount to learn the proper
safety dancing for example this means
I'm turning left this means I'm turning
right and most importantly this means
stop now that we've taken the proper
measures it's time to stay safe have fun
[Music]
[Music]
homebody fridge with steven crowder and
not a jerry sponsored by mud cloth
[Music]
[Music]
I don't I don't know what that is I was
trying to be flexible I picture their
dances requirement rated it a lot of
flexibility they do I have idea
apparently not super flexible as a
culture though as seen by defecating in
streets fifty percent fifty percent of
Indians defecate we're by the way
little-known fact I don't people going
to get really mad so fifty percent of
Indians go out in the open
true story I swear as well for the first
time ever hopper got sick and and
defecated it he had an accident house he
used the corner so uh let's consider
breed thank you so much Dave Rubin Dave
Cohen please follow them support them
and big big week next week next week we
have will be in New York we'll be
broadcasting from New York because we're
going for a YouTube conference some of
its super secretive but I think we're
the only conservatives who have been
invited out there to this summit
so we'll be broadcasting on Wednesday
from New York City Gavin McGinnis will
be with us I think my lawyer bill
Richman will be with us we have a well I
think we have a nice iris on Monday and
then Tuesday we have a full one-hour
discussion with Dennis preggers to sit
down people's regular and so much in the
show they said listen I would love it if
you could have a long-term sit-down with
him he's he's a guy whose brain I just
love to pick young he knows his stuff
and it's funny you know before doctor
for dr. Peterson and a lot of people
have really found they found a lot of a
lot of satisfaction they've a lot of
personal growth in people who will
administer sort of these long-form
videos or pieces of content they'll
actually sit and listen which remember
when the internet started there was no
way they're like no it's a short always
got to be short short short short to the
proper now YouTube actually their
monetization is based on length they
want things to be longer yeah and they
actually were incentivizing people by
putting in more commercial breaks but
what's funny cuz Facebook doesn't seem
to get that they still seem the Facebook
platform lends itself to really short
because it's the tender span of know
like it's there and gone cause it's
scrolling through a timeline timeline
but that's not the general right think
across the internet as a whole and you
know that's actually that's proof
positive that people who actually hope
gosh my hair there's no way to get this
right after the wig now during the
breaks I gotta now it just went it's
just now it's hard to get all headphones
I give up
that's one thing Indians they have
luscious thick hair good on them and
mustaches can't go
beards though but this is proof positive
whenever someone says oh this culture is
lost I remember talking with some
relatives he said these kids they have
an attention span of of 30 seconds
that's all you can do I read a study
that that's although watching online
video for that was true when it started
but here's the thing when an entire
generation of people grow up with a
technology that was new to you they
adapt and the technology adapts another
example remember pop-ups how intrusive
pop-ups were now if you go to a news
site of something you you occasionally
get like a pop-up or pop under ad would
you really aggravate to me I'm not
talking about a pop-up signup for
mailing lists we all kind of expect that
you close it down number one you started
the what he did your little Netscape
Navigator is accountable it was just pop
up after you it was a roll of the dice
every time you went to a new URL yeah by
the way my my first experience that was
a group vegetales fan own I thought I
thought LarryBoy com might have been a
good good thing that turns out it just
riddles your page with pop-ups it's like
your hard drive has AIDS only there is
no cure there's no magic Johnson you
live with it your computer was done that
got better people adapted kind of like
there were no young conservatives on
YouTube when we started sometimes things
get better and I know the doom and gloom
cells everybody ad space and the
conservative side but I will say this
I'm really do have a lot of hope for our
generation for generations that follow I
do I absolutely do technology has gotten
better kids have become more safe online
they're more protected yeah there's some
bad that comes with it I think people
are disconnected with social media but I
think you're gonna see the next
generation they've grown up with social
media that they go it's kind of old hat
and their thing will probably be to get
in drum circles everything old is new
again one thing I will say we're getting
letters already were getting tweets
about the cultural appropriation yes we
did it and yes I don't expect to have a
show at a mainstream network anytime
soon I'm okay with it I'm fine with it
all right but one thing is is is uh by
the way we also have Michael Voris
coming on the show to convert me to
Catholicism that actually made the
rounds I said if anyone you know wants
to come on and we can discuss Catholic
theology because I had a few people who
said if you were a true seeker you'll
become a Catholic we're going to do a
credible show convert cried a week and I
do mean that genuinely I think we have
way more in common that we knew
differences but this would be a good way
to discuss theological and philosophical
differences by popular demand it's
happening by a popular demand Michael
Voris and also something hopefully a
Thea
can conclude something from it should be
interesting to learn the differences in
certain I guess you would say verticals
of Christianity but I will say this when
this happened and people are talking
about converting crowd or to Catholicism
that was why if you thought there was no
kind of segue in my brain I remember in
the comments section some people were
saying you know I really orbit through
Jordan Peterson or you'll probably get
it with Dennis Prager you know I really
wish Crowder just stopped joke I really
wish they stop joking over there him and
Jared or smile I just it's just it's
just too much I just wish they were more
serious they could do a lot of good if
they were more serious first off that's
not going to happen
now if you watch the hour plus interview
with Jordan Peterson it is pretty
serious and actually if you compare it
to other interviews with any famous
youtubers ours got into much deeper
theological discussion he even said as
much I mean if they were more
challenging questions people here are
actually pretty pretty educated
I wouldn't say blackbelt IQs but
certainly above the room average um same
with Dennis Prager yeah we're gonna try
and keep it funny this is an
entertainment program but this is
something that I think is important on
the right you cannot and this happened
was with this Catholic post where people
are saying I wish you were more serious
you can do better if you were more
serious you cannot [ __ ] you cannot
complain about the fall of Western
civilization culture and say you know
the youth they've been corrupted through
decadent or through vote through through
entertainment and through film and
through music that's all these kids care
about look they don't know what it what
it's like anymore they don't know what
our days were because they don't know
what the real will everything with them
is entertainment we've lost them because
of a corrupt culture you cannot give the
culture that much power and then strip
conservatives or the right wing of using
it you can't do that and then say you
know what you'd be a lot more effective
if you sermonize that's one thing and
you know what it is
you don't believe it people out there
because a lot of followers say this too
or they say you know IIIi watch this or
my pastor net we love your show but then
some people in the church complain and
say why are you watching this and well
you know what do you say to you do you
think it might be more effective listen
I think there are some people out there
who are more effective being serious and
I also think that some people there's a
particular person who emailed me this
week asking if he thought that maybe he
should abandon his approach that he was
kind of the funny guy and wasn't taken
seriously but was pretty smart and and
he felt bad about it no I don't think
me too I think humor and entertainment
is incredibly valuable tool and the
right has has empowered it by baking it
out to be the big bad boogeyman but then
when the right is able to be just as
powerful they condemn it and they
condemn you so if that's who you are and
that's who we are on the show you should
be authentic to that that's the one
thing where conservatives have lost so
much ground is they've expect if you go
to a college Republicans meeting
certainly 10 years ago I don't almost
like now it looked like a Tucker Carlson
jr. look-alike convention I'm talking
free nhanh bowtie Tucker Carlson no the
gimmick with a bow tie and then pledge
Jack it's kind of Don Cherry that took
her Carlson era no one looked different
no one acted differently and that's a
bad thing and I think the reason you're
seeing this upswing and you're seeing on
YouTube this that this conservative
fighting back this battlefront where
we're actually winning is because think
about it Dave Rubin Dave Cullen think of
whoever else uh you know Milo obviously
is somebody you have someone like a
Tommy Lauren you have someone like an O
and Benjamin there are so many different
people in so many different voices I
don't think it's a coincidence that only
since that has happened some black guy
was one of them that only since that has
occurred that you've seen conservatism
and the ability to communicate its ideas
to a new generation bloom so to the
person who emails me no I don't think
that if you're known as the funny guy
and people don't take you seriously I
don't think you need to change your
approach just like we're not going to
change our approach the reason that
we've taken this approach how many times
have you heard
think about it though isin they're
considered answer daily show all eight
nights you it's all a left-wing
everything it's just Samantha bee The
Daily Show Stephen Colbert Jimmy here's
a [ __ ] about her old so yeah well guess
what you have it now here we are this is
it if you have a problem with it you're
just somebody who likes to [ __ ]
professionally and that's fine to do in
the comments section on this show really
because we don't expect everyone to like
this I'm surprised as many people watch
this show as they do but don't do it in
your churches don't do it in your social
groups don't do it in your schools don't
do it in your College Republicans group
where if someone there is a little
different and someone likes to have a
laugh and someone likes to bring some
levity to a situation don't condemn them
don't tell money to be more
shuri's because that's creating this
that's that's piety and it's false and
it doesn't help anybody so think of
someone maybe this week going forward in
your life maybe you've done that or
maybe you felt people who've done that
to you tell them not listen you know
what I'm not gonna do it your way
don't do it somebody else's way because
they say so and if you are telling other
people to do it your way we're not
talking about principle or the message
but if you find yourself ever telling
someone they need to change their
packaging and I'm sure I'm guilty of
this at some point they're probably been
people you know everyone pushes button
from search to others push but but do
you find yourself doing that or if you
find yourself in a situation where
someone is doing it to you stop it or
stop them and tell them I'm okay
I don't you do things your way you know
why because America not India by the way
more cultural appropriation next month
tomorrow is warning grinder for multiple
members and we'll see you Monday for
mugful members if not
[Music]
you